David your first reaction when you heard
of this transaction I don't know if I
could say it on the air but I was you
know I was stunned by anyone as I was
that the what's F but they call that i
also got from your producers not long
ago so I mean honestly here's a guy who
who really has gigantic ambitions this
was this is my first impression of him
when i met him in 2006 and it remains
why is the strong impression of him more
so in fact every day i don't think it's
crazy the money is a lot but i think
when you think about really facebook as
a company whose goal is to make the
world more open and connected that's the
long term correction that this continues
to point but david on a financial basis
which you covered for years with Fortune
magazine on a financial basis this is
not a two billion dollar transaction
it's a four hundred million dollar
transaction a lot of funny money
attached is that right if somebody right
if somebody said today if you're making
billions sent rating at a hundred PE you
have a lot of flexibility to buy things
and you know it's probably the smart
move in an industry that changes as
quickly as the internet does and as
technology does he's positioning it's a
kind of hedge in a way but it's also a
vision for the future that I think it's
been some ways extremely optimistic
which is another characteristic of this
extremely unusual leader right we
actually want to give you a sense of
what the co founder and the CEO of
oculus told our bradstone they sat down
about a week ago before Facebook made
this purchase take a listen there's a
lot to get it out there it's one thing
to make a prototype that's in a room
that can't be moved it's another thing
to make it you know a few hundred
dollars in a mass-market mass consumer
eyes form factor that you can ship out
to the world so we definitely have a
number of challenges ahead but we're
getting closer David there's a lot of
questions about whether virtual
realities applications can be
commercially viable beyond gaming what
do you think it's it's a it's not even
in question in my opinion I mean in
reality you know there will be future
technology
the idea of presence of being in the
feeling that you will be there with
someone else is without even really
knowing in some cases I think in the
free long distance if there whether
you're really there or not certainly the
illusion this is an inevitability I
think in technology that's been assumed
for a long time the reason that oculus
is so important is that this is the
first time that it affordable technology
has emerged it really gives people that
opportunity it's still in a super early
phase but you know you know what the key
thing to think about with oculus is it
is a platform it's a platform that
others are going to build businesses and
services on top of which means that if
it continues to fulfill its promise it
is a gigantic opportunity it is not the
same opportunity as running to Facebook
service necessarily but it is a gigantic
potential business